c'est ainsi qu'aujourd'hui deux français
sur dix compte un parent âgé qui n'est
plus autonome 1988 le vieillissement
croissant de la population inquiétait le
gouvernement
face au manque de places dans les
structures spécialisées
le premier ministre jacques chirac
appelait alors à la solidarité nationale
nous devons assumer à leur égard nos
responsabilités aujourd'hui plus de 4
millions de personnes accompagnent
régulièrement un proche de 60 ans et
plus des aidants familiaux qui
consacrent leur temps et leur énergie
un proche âgés et dépendants ou pas
c'est un petit peu chez nous on ne peut
plus sortir dans ne peut plus inviter
les amis qu'on veut une aide
indispensable peu reconnue à cette
époque par les pouvoirs publics
seuls quelques initiatives locales
permettait aux aidants de souffler
pendant quelques jours ce soir monsieur
et madame keynes partent en vacances
pendant leur absence
une association des deux personnes âgées
organisera des gardes à domicile un
service peu remboursés par les caisses
de retraite dans les années 90 pour se
serrer les coudes les aidants familiaux
commençait à se réunir plus que du temps
pour se reposer
ils réclamaient surtout une
reconnaissance économique de leur
investissement quotidien le risque
dépendance n'est actuellement reconnue
par aucun organisme de sécurité sociale
et c'est justement ce que je souhaite
le collectif que nous représentons
aujourd'hui que ce risque soit reconnue
pour être pris en charge normalement par
la solidarité nationale
comme tous les autres risques de la
sécurité sociale cette demande restera
vaine jusqu'en 2006 le gouvernement a
annoncé alors la création d'un congé de
soutien familial une pause de trois mois
renouvelable mais non rémunérée accordée
à tous les salariés pour s'occuper d'un
parent dépendant
une avancée notable mais pas suffisante
selon seth et dante
je pense qu'en effet ça peut être une
bonne idée mais que très peu de
personnes pourront en bénéficier dans la
mesure où un salaire par exemple un
petit peu plus élevé que le smic
en aucun cas on peut se permettre de 200
de s'en priver
dix ans plus tard en 2016 un droit de
répit entre est en vigueur pour la
première fois une aide financière de 500
euros par an était accordée à l'est dans
un dispositif encore trop insuffisant
pour cette femme en charge son mari
atteint d'alzheimer c'est pas miraculeux
non faut pas croire qu'il nous faut un
gros cadeau en juillet 2019
agnès buzyn la ministre de la santé a
annoncé une évolution majeure dans la
reconnaissance du statut d'aidant un
congé de trois mois rémunéré entre 40 et
50 euros par jour
il devrait entrer en vigueur à l'automne
[Musique]